[Music]
hello everyone welcome back from lunch
welcome back to the culminating keynote
for our exploration symposium it's just
an incredible pleasure to introduce dr.
Peter Diamandis Peters is a chairman and
CEO of the XPrize foundation the CEO of
zero gravity corporation the chairman
and co-founder of rocket Racing League
co-founder and director of space
adventures co-founder of the
International Space University and the
list goes on but more importantly to me
Peter's a a dear friend colleague help
me get through graduate school at this
place and we had some great great times
in graduate school in the thing that I'd
like to tell you about Peter is person I
know most kind of embodies endless
energy ideas dreams and then makes them
come true so I'm very excited and
welcome you all in in welcoming Peter
Diamandis to give our keynote the
culmination of our symposium thank you
[Applause]
can you guys hear me mics up great and I
remember the day that Dave a finished
her doctorate and and we had the
conversation about what was she gonna do
next and I said you should really stay
it on my tee and teach you cuz no way no
way in the world that's the last place I
want to go and how many years later is
it amazing I want to start with a with a
the sense that I love this place I
haven't been here for a decade or two
but I love what MIT represents in terms
of anything being possible and I
remember when I came here as undergrad I
was just impassioned with opportunity I
want to take a moment first of all to
recognize my thesis adviser dr. Larry
young and the whole team at mvl when I
was a third-year medical student at at
Harvard med school I was panicking
because I had no interest in practicing
and I was having to pick where I was
gonna do my internship and residency and
I called him up in a in a panic one day
and saying dr. young I really I have to
come back and do my course 16 course
work and and Larry said sure and that
gave me the time to get my head around
it and escape doing the internship and
residency so I want sorry and we ended
up doing my my thesis work on short arm
centrifugal artificial gravity sleep or
the idea that you can sleep while you're
in zero-g and you can use the time eight
hours while you're sleeping 4G loading
to help reduce the negative effects of
weightlessness but that's not the
subject of my conversation today I want
to talk to you about really inspiring
breakthroughs and innovation and
exploration and I'm gonna give you the
punchline first and then I want to share
with you the stories of the last 20
years of my my travels my endeavor is to
try and make this come true the fact the
matter is today more than ever a small
group or a group of individuals can
literally do what governments could do
before that each of you is empowered to
be explore
in the oceans and the air in space that
doesn't take a national budget behind
you the technologies that are coming
online in AI and robotics and quantum
computing embedded networks and new
materials are going to transform the
cost and the capabilities so the
question is what are your most
passionate about going to do because
we're about to enter a golden age of
exploration that's going to enable not a
few governments but hopefully thousands
of individuals and thousands of small
corporations to go out there and explore
beyond the bonds of earth so let's see
there we go so my my passions have been
embodied in this phrase that the best
way to predict the future is created
yourself and I believe that we're now
entering a period in time where you can
in fact predict the future and go off
and create it because if you don't do it
who is and if you're sitting here in the
audience as an undergrad or a graduate
student please know that the future that
you create is completely and totally up
to you it's not up to governments not to
a corporation it's what you've made a
personal commitment to go and do and you
can go and explore Mars the asteroids
the oceans whatever it is the power is
within you to get the capital the
technology and the people together to go
and make that happen so when I think
about my dreams my dreams were embodied
when when Buzz was an astronaut his
missions and his work really got me
excited when I was born in the 60s to
want to go and open up space that's been
my mission in life my passions and I've
thought about how do I do that and how
do I do that outside of the government
how do I do that privately and I
starting about what drives exploration
what drives people to go and do this
this is a colleague of buzzes this is um
this is December 1972
it's Gene Cernan he's literally jumping
up a meter off the moon and he said if
we could have gone from having never put
a human into space to landing on the
moon eight and a half years later you
tell me what's impossible nothing is
impossible and I remember those words
and I
of them that the fact that matter is
especially today there is no barrier
that cannot be overcome the question is
what drives us to explore and I would
posit that there are a number of key
drivers first and foremost is fear fear
has been one of the major drivers of
exploration beyond our borders and and
this is JFK responding to split Nick and
Gagarin and saying we're going to the
moon and coming back for it into the
decade driven in part by the US need to
demonstrate its capabilities it's a fear
response to competition curiosity is
there life out there in the universe you
know an important response but far
weaker than fear in fact you can
actually measure the ratio of fear to
curiosity as a driver it's the ratio of
the defense budget to the science budget
funny but sad wealth creation one of for
me one of the most important elements of
exploration can we in fact go out there
and create wealth wealth of information
wealth of capital if you think about the
fact that you know in the before 1984 we
had never drilled in more than a hundred
feet of water in offshore drilling and
that when shell discovered this large
deposit literally tens of thousands of
feet below the ocean surface and then
tens of thousands of feet below the
ocean floor that they bet a billion
dollars to go and look at deep-sea oil
platform drilling and today the average
project is between five to fifty billion
dollars huge capital investments to
create wealth
the final driver for me is significance
the inner heartfelt drive of a human to
need to do something significant in
their lifetime and nobody embodies this
better than the story for for Charles
Lindbergh which was the story that got
me going on the XPrize which I'll tell a
little bit of now turns out that
Lindbergh responded to a prize offered
up by a Frenchman Raymond Orteig who in
1919 offered up the audacious prize of
25,000 parts
and most people laughed at the time they
said it was impossible cannot be done
and there was a promise that it might
happen but eight years later in 1927
nine different teams including Lindbergh
had spent four hundred thousand dollars
to try and win this twenty five thousand
dollar prize and Lindbergh was the most
unlikely guy to do it had been called
the flying fool it all been flying for
two years so much so that no one would
sell him an airplane or an engine
because they were so afraid that he
would crash on takeoff and destroy their
reputation but just the opposite
happened Lindbergh made the flight in
thirty three and a half hours later he
made it to Paris but something else
really happened which really got my
attention as I was reading this book it
turns out that between 1927 just before
he took off to 1929 18 months later the
number of passengers the United States
went from 6,000 to 180,000 was a 30-fold
increase in passenger traffic and people
who were flying airplanes went from
Daredevils and aeronauts to pilots and
passengers his dramatic demonstration of
crossing the Atlantic literally changed
the face of aviation and made it
possible for everybody and so I learned
that a dramatic demonstration that
enters the human psyche whether it's the
four-minute mile or Apollo 11 or Charles
Lindbergh can be transformative to
create markets and belief of what is
possible so if you're looking for
changing the world in a big and bold
fashion look at a way that's going to
penetrate human psyche and do something
that people remember for the rest of
their lives so I started studying prizes
because I said well here's an idea to
get myself and my friends up in space
without having to go the route of the
government you see while I was in
Larry's lab I also got a chance to meet
someone you met yesterday Byron
Lichtenberg who was sort of an older
brother to me and I asked Byron about
the realities of becoming an astronaut
and he said well you know your chances
are one in a thousand of getting
accepted and even if you're accepted you
know half the astronauts have never
flown to call them penguins because they
have wings but they can't fly and I said
well what makes the decision on who gets
to fly and they say well if you do what
you're told and you're a good boy
I said forget it I'm never gonna get a
chance to fly so I said prize is that's
how I'm gonna get a chance to go so I
read about the longitude prize we heard
about a little bit earlier thousands of
humans were losing their lives and the
rocks the British Admiralty put up a
large prize in the early 1700s for the
person who could tell the longitude as
well as latitude and they all expected
that an astronomer would win right
astronomers were the coolest dudes the
smartest guys in fact they were on the
judging panel of the longitude judging
panel but here comes this watchmaker
this tinkerer this guy who comes up with
these two watches the h1 and the h2 and
says I've done it I've solved the riddle
of telling longitude and everybody said
no no you haven't no it's gonna be
solved by an astronomer they're the
experts it took 40 years for him to
actually get the longitude prize and
what I learned from that is a lot of
times a true breakthrough comes from an
orthogonal angle from someplace you
least expect it from someone who's
outside the norm and the experts are
there telling you exactly how it can't
be done so think about that when you're
looking for breakthroughs so the
question was how was I gonna get myself
into space by the time I had finished
reading Lindbergh's autobiography spirit
of st. Louis the idea of creating a
prize for a private spaceflight came to
mind it was gonna be a 10 million dollar
competition for a vehicle you carry
three adults up into space come down
safely land and do it again within two
weeks all right I figured at the end of
this kind of a competition there would
be a vehicle that could go into private
business so at that point I went on
stage in st. Louis and you can see in
the audience there to my left is Byron
Lichtenberg and to my right is dr.
Aldrin I didn't have any prize money and
I didn't have any teams but what I did
was try to give birth to this idea above
the line of super credibility so I had
not only Buzz and Byron but we had 20
astronauts on stage the Lindbergh family
the head of the FAA
and was even able to get dan gold in the
head of NASA there and so we announced
his competition for private spaceflight
with front-page around the world and no
one asked to have any money which we
didn't and do have any teams which we
did not but they took it seriously which
was wonderful because I expected without
any question it would be a piece of cake
who would not want to pay the 10 million
dollars after someone pulled it off well
I was wrong I spent about five or six
years at that point going from CEO to
CEO to CMO and saying you know we'll
call it the FedEx XPrize we'll call it
the Virgin XPrize the GM XPrize and so
forth and Branson and Fred Smith and all
the rest said well why isn't NASA doing
it and can anyone really do it and you
know is someone gonna die trying and
does it really have to be that much
money and ultimately in 2001 after I had
had every team calling me saying
Diamandis do you have the money yet I
met this woman I was reading about
anusha Ansari in the pages of Forbes
magazine and it said in her bio she just
sold a company to sonís networks for a
billion dollars and it's in her bio and
her dream was to fly on a sub orbital
flight into space and I can't tell you
many times I read that line a suborbital
flight into space I tracked her down
vacationing in Hawaii I was her first
meeting when she got back to Dallas and
they literally agreed on the spot and we
made it
the Ansari X PRIZE in honor to them well
it worked we had 26 teams from seven
countries around the world who spent 26
I'm sorry 100 million dollars to try and
win the prize and this was the vehicle
spaceship one underneath white night one
were any people in the audience who were
at that flight we've got about a half
dozen or so
October 4th 2004 in the Mojave Desert we
had about 30,000 people show up from
around the world to be here at that
historic event and here's the vehicle
under power burning poly butadiene tire
rubber and nitrous oxide laughing gas
and one of the things that I've learned
is when you put on a competition teams
or
to try new things and take risks that
the traditional players might not
otherwise take and the vehicle at
altitude for the pilots there in the
audience the N number here three to
eight kilo Foxtrot is 328 thousand feet
which is pretty cool which was 100
kilometres by the way and after landing
on the second flight they had won the
Ansari X PRIZE it was start of a new era
to my right of the Ansari s to my left
Paul Allen who had funded to his left
Burt Rutan and to his left Brian Binney
who had made the second flight and then
Richard Branson who literally licensed
the rights to that vehicle that week to
go and create a Virgin Galactic so we
had 10 billion media impressions which
was really cool we made the front page
of Google which almost took down our
servers that was really cool too and we
the vehicle made it into the Air and
Space Museum right above Apollo 11 and
next the spirit of st. Louis the most
visited spot literally in the world more
than the Louvre I'd like to do is take
you back via a short video to those
moments we're announcing today something
called the XPrize a 10 million dollar
contest to privately build a spaceship
that's able to carry three individuals
fly to 100 kilometers altitude
and do that twice inside of two weeks
I have never been myself as creative as
I have pi ball in this goddamn fries
welcome to my hobby here in the high
desert of California on this incredible
day my you are gonna witness history in
the mating
[Music]
the Ansari X PRIZE inspired
international competition drove
regulatory reform and made history a
personal spaceflight revolution so after
the XPrize was one we saw the birth of a
few companies Virgin Galactic
for example now selling seats at 200,000
in the midst of its drop test I think
it's on its sixteenth or so flight in
addition one of my company space
adventures partnered with armadillo and
is doing vertical take-off vertical
landing suborbital and you can see the
price competition already it's coming in
a hundred and five thousand we'll see
where the prices of Ridge end up finally
the hallmarks of a great prize
historically if you can design it
properly is the following it's highly
leveraged you get 10 to 40 times the
prize purse spent cuman about all the
teams to try and win it you only pay the
winner you know fixed cost engineering
and fixed cost science if you would you
spark not one player but an entire
industry and for me the most important
part is you get non-traditional
solutions you get high risk being taken
but all of these teams trying to do it
and so rather than backing a single
approach you back very non-traditional
approaches so we're doing prizes now in
a range of groups life sciences
exploration energy education and global
development and I'm gonna just focus a
little bit on where we're doing in the
exploration realm so the next prize we
have up for grabs is the 30 million
dollar Google Lunar XPrize and I'm very
proud that there is a team here from
from MIT
giant leap and if this technology well I
believe this technology can be developed
I believe this prize will be won but
when it does it is going to usher in the
capability for private individuals
universities and corporations literally
to go and land a rover on the moon and
that's transformative so much so that
this past year NASA put up an additional
30 million dollars in contracts for
teams that are able to go and compete
for the Google Lunar XPrize I like to do
is show a short video
of Sergey Brin a lot of companies have a
sponsor a variety of things just as kind
of marketing to support their brand what
not
sometimes sports teams sometimes
sailboats I knew that we never wanted to
do something so conventional at Google I
thought if we were ever to sponsor
something it should be something
ambitious so we now have 29 teams around
the world each vying to go and build
these vehicles if we do the job right
this is the youtubes generation Apollo
moon race and one of the things that's
very cool is we're gonna have
competitions for the teenager who
decides what YouTube video should be
sent back from the moon or what's the
first text message being sent back from
these vehicles in addition to 10
million-dollar prizes we have these X
challenges which are typically 1 to 2
million-dollar prizes I can tell you
about one of them this was an X
challenge called the Northrop Grumman
lunar lander X challenge for developing
new vertical take-off vertical landing
capabilities so what was offered was 2
million dollars of money put up by NASA
North her put up the put up the
Operations dollars and teams had to go
up 50 meters translate 50 meters do a
land power landing refuel and go back
again so we had nine actually 11
different teams that registered for the
competition and at the end of the day
two of the teams hit all the
requirements but was really cool about
this was that John Carmack and Dave
Mastan who were the two winners
literally did not come out of the
aerospace industry they were both
software programmers so I'm always
looking at where the breakthroughs come
from traditionally not from the
traditional players and this is very
cool Dave Mastan makes the sort of
Entrepreneur of the year on Aviation
Week I'm gonna take you back to one of
the early flights now where John Carmack
is demonstrating one of his vehicles
Pixel and I want you to pay close
attention to what he says at the end
all right we're gonna start the clock I
believe correct the clock is rolling
there it is two and a half hours folks
so two and a half hours this team has
got to get the vehicle on the truck
they've got to get out to the land the
launch zone a ten meter concrete pad out
there in the desert
takeoff fly at 50 meters altitude flight
down a path 100 meters long to another
landing pad if they need to refuel
refuel come back repeat the same thing
and come back to the same pad and then
get back here in two and half hours if
they do it they'll be the first team to
have done it four three two one
what's higher than yesterday's test
flight
[Music]
the target
[Applause]
all right I think the best benefit that
NASA can possibly get out of this is an
operation like this going from concept
to successful almost successful flight
here in under six months by team of
eight people part-time for about
$200,000 that should shame some of their
current contractors that are going to be
spending tens of billions of dollars
doing different things
I love that we'll come back to that a
little bit
so where's XPrize going in exploration
we're looking at deep ocean exploration
looking at a new generation of subs for
taking humans down there we're looking
at robotic competitions for ocean open
mapping the ocean floor point-to-point
beamed power I'll speak about that in a
few minutes electric aircraft
competitions asteroid detection
deflection orbital debris even a
competition for sort of an eye gem
competition can you create a life-form
that can grow under Martian conditions
and taste good so the question for me is
how do we get ourselves into space and
how do we do it independent of
government budgets and government cycles
and the challenge if you guys don't know
this the problem is that in the early
1960s we went to the moon it was a very
different Congress a very different way
of budgeting we could make literally a
decade-long commitment that we can't do
anymore and in the beginning we had the
ability to do literally cherry-pick
things where there would be an event
every six months or an event every year
Mercury Gemini Apollo that kept
literally the eye candy in the sight of
the voters it's no longer like that so
the ability to go into space for me is
about two options number one is how do
we reduce the activation energy which
means bringing the cost of going into
space down or the flip side of the
equation how do we heat up the how do we
heat it up how do we get more
participation and more demand so that's
it those are the two options that we
have so in terms of how do we bring it
down the cost down the situation today
is expensive obviously the shuttles
going away but as a if you could have
bought a ticket you know 120 million
dollars a seat my other company space
adventures the seat price now is 45
million so you can go to the capitalists
Russians if you want to lower costume
and if you've done one of dr. Hoffman's
classes you probably have calculated
what the total cost of going into space
you can
calculate MGH 1/2 MV squared for you and
your spacesuit and if you buy it at 7
cents a kilowatt-hour off the grid the
cost of getting you and your spacesuit
into orbit is about a hundred bucks so
somewhere between 100 million in a
hundred bucks is the efficiencies that
we're gonna have hopefully not creating
you physics but new engineering how will
we get there reusable Falcons are one
way
Ilan's got a commitment to making his
vehicles reusable and if you stop and
you look at what the cost of the
kerosene and the locks for a falcon 9
would be it's about you know one hundred
and fifty thousand dollars if you look
at amateur transportation industry a car
a boat and a plane the cost of operating
that is about three times the cost of
fuel so if you really can make it
reusable and three times the cost of
fuel okay that's for $50,000 seven
people on board you've got a price per
seat below 100k and that's pretty cool
ways I'm looking at that I'm excited
about is can you reinvent how we get
into space because ultimately all the
rockets we use today our multi you know
our thousand-year-old
derivatives of Chinese fire work you
burn something the middle hot gases come
out the other end so this concept of
using power on the ground microwave
laser and beaming it to the vehicle and
heating up a work at fluent the working
fluid hydrogen for me is one of the
promising ideas because it puts this
system on Moore's law you can get mass
fractions of 25 to 30 percent you can
get these vehicles reusable and you can
really get ISPs upwards of a thousand
and transform how we get into space so
one other idea which of these or others
might work
I don't know but none of these things
are gonna happen unless the market is
there so ultimately the question is how
do you drive participation and demand so
let me speak about that and some of the
things I played with so Eric Anderson
Mike McDonald and I started a company
called space adventures we have a
opportunity with the Russians to take
people up to this up to this 5-star
multi hundred billion dollar hotel
called ISS we have had eight clients go
up so far
our fifth and seventh client were in
fact the same Charles Simoni so from
Dennis Tito who's celebrating next this
Friday in fact his tenth anniversary of
his flight to Gila liberté from the
founder of Cirque de Soleil there's a
new Chinon sorry up in the right who is
the patron saint of my XPrize and an
Richard Garriott whose father was was
also an Apollo astronaut Skylab
astronaut and as Byron mentioned
yesterday one of the new products that
we've signed a deal with the Russians is
for a saloon or flight basically an
Apollo 8 mission at a price probably in
120 million dollar friend League but you
know there's 1,400 billionaires that we
know of on this planet and you know
what's 120 million dollars for a trip to
the moon and back so when I was a grad
student here with byron one of the
things I got very excited about was the
chance to go and do zero-g flights and I
became passionate about this idea and in
1993 Byron and I walked into the FAA and
announced our decision that we were
going to go and commercialize zero-g and
the conversation went something like
this
Peter Byron can you show me where in the
Federal Aviation Regulations it allows
you to fly parabolic flights and I said
no can you show me where it doesn't and
they proceeded to show me where it
doesn't know
it didn't really say that but it turns
out that you know if you think about it
somewhere over the last hundred years we
went in our regulatory framework from
the point of if it's not used to be if
it was not explicitly prohibited you
could do it to the point now if it's not
explicitly allowed you can't do it and
that's a very dangerous change that's
occurred for the you know the policy
students here and it literally took us
11 years we went and had our first move
FAA in May of 93
we got operational authority in
September of 2004 so I was talking to
some students earlier down in the
restroom about and don't start with why
we start the conversation there but
about what do you do in your life
it's you know you pick something you're
passionate about I guarantee you I would
have given up a thousand times and so in
Byron if we'd not been passionate about
making this happen but now we have our
zero-g airplane we have flown 350
flights we've flown over 12,000 people
into zero-g and you know it's the
world's largest roller coaster with 30
seconds of weight-loss followed by 30
seconds of weight gain
you
so you get the picture in a in a special
cameo by dr. Aldrin here who's been kind
enough to fly with us on numerous
occasions one of the coolest things that
we had a chance to do was to actually
fly Stephen Hawking into zero-g and I'll
tell that story very briefly I had met
dr. Hawking through the arc on genomics
XPrize where he's one of the genomes
that were sequencing and he said him
during our first conversation his dream
was to fly in a space I said I can't fly
into space but I could take you up into
zero-g and which he said absolutely we
announced it the next day and I got two
phone calls one from our aircraft
operations partner who said what are you
crazy
another one from a government agency I
won't say who they are but their
initials or the FAA and and saying can't
do it and I literally cannot do that
your rules and regulations allow you
only to fly able-bodied individuals and
I was I was literally taken aback by
this and everybody I spoke to said
you're risking your company if you do
this this man is as feeble and you know
osteoporosis and cardiac this and
pulmonary that and I said you know if we
can't fly him that's the reason we
worked 11 years to go and try and build
this company so ultimately as you're out
there building your companies and your
exploration missions you're gonna be
faced with choices about do you stand
for what you starred the company or the
organization for or are you gonna back
down every time there's a risk because
we're killing ourselves in this nation
who risk adverse we've gotten so
ultimately I said absolutely not we're
gonna make this happen and I went and
got a panel of for physicians to
literally write the FAA and tell them
that he was an able-bodied individual
and we got them on the flight and five
months later here we are at the Kennedy
Space Center at the tarmac at a
preflight press conference where we
announced the intention to a single
30-second parabola and if things went
really well
we might do two or three we took off
here out of the SLS we had set up an
emergency room on board the airplane we
were following his po2 his cardiac
pulmonary everything and we actually did
a full up
dress rehearsal a day before with a 15
year old physics high-school student who
had the same height and weight we did
every possible emergency routine on this
poor kid in zero-g
we're taking off here out of the slf
here's byron who you met yesterday my
co-founder and and sort of older
brothers and i lifting dr. Hawking
during the first parabola furious with a
sort of a cautious smile on his face and
at the end of the first parabola
he was rock solid I turned the
physicians they gave a thumbs-up here's
our second parabola and our third
parabola we flew an Apple in homage to
Sir Isaac Newton because dr. Hawking
holds the same seat at Cambridge that
Sir Isaac Newton did and so at the end
of three parabolas I said you know we
should stop and he said no and through
his translators and we went to four five
and six and finally by the eighth
parabola I said that's it and and this
is him on his eighth parabola and he had
an extraordinary experience but our goal
here was again to give the public the
chance to personally participate in
space and exploration just like like
Geoff Grayson and XCore and virgin and
armadillo and all of these companies are
doing it's how do you make it possible
for everybody to have a chance to play
so that there's a real vibrancy and it's
not just for one of those 500 astronauts
so one of the other things I've been
working on is building a real a real
business and I went to my first auto
race in 2001 and after the cars went me
immune I got bored and when I get bored
I think about putting rockets on things
and so the rocket racing league was born
at that point and we made the cover of
popular science we first announced it I
will call out to the XCore and Geoff
Grayson who did a lot of the early
engine development and helped us get the
company off the ground I'm very greatly
appreciative for that
here's the the vehicle at a recent Air
and Space show that we did we're trying
to reinvent racing for the 22nd century
and if you stop and you realize that
NASCAR and Formula One racing are each
five billion dollar properties I think
there's plenty of opportunity to create
technology and new businesses so this is
the vehicle it's a single pilot vehicle
that is flied through a
three-dimensional racecourse and I'll be
showing you video here in a second here
we are in Tulsa Oklahoma where we are
loading up liquid oxygen and kerosene on
these vehicles both the same time I
think it's one of the only operations
that two vehicles are being loaded with
rocket fuels simultaneously here's Dez
Ramon are doing the the loading of the
kerosene in this and this in the alcohol
in this case and here's two vehicles on
the runway and you can see literally
from from zero to take off in under four
seconds which is quite the kick in the
pants
and one of the things that we've done is
part of this company is really to merge
in all of the cutting-edge technologies
so we have brought in augmented reality
and augmented television we're literally
on the jumbotron
at the TV at home or on your iPad you
see the racecourse superimposed the same
racecourse the pilot sees and their
heads up display and at the same time
we've developed a whole video game
multiplayer series that allows you to
actually play the video game in real
time as these vehicles are transmitting
the differential GPS signal so you can
fly against them and find out who's
better so I'm gonna go to video here so
you can see get a feeling for where this
company is going
here's a site and a sound that will get
your heart pumping pair of rocket racers
in the sky thousands of spectators
cheering them on and coming along for
the ride virtually it's great the
technology is awesome you know how in
the world they can pull this off and
it's just amazing it was the first time
two rocket racers flew together in front
of more than 30,000 people it happened
at the Kwik Trip Tulsa air and rocket
racing show and it was the realization
of a decade old dream of rocket racing
league founder Peter Diamandis but when
I saw those two vehicles coming off the
runway one afternoon that wasn't that
was the payoff for all the hard work
rocket racing is a mash-up between star
wars pod racers and NASCAR DeltaWing
velocity aircraft are rigged up with
rocket motors built by armadillo
aerospace which can generate 2,000
pounds of thrust in an instant now
that's a kick in a propeller or a driven
aircraft or we're near to jet you wind
up on the power and you can feel it
coming in as you move the throttle
forward here you flip a switch and you
go from no thrust to full thrust in less
than a second and you feel that kick in
your back rocket racing uses high
technology to bring fans along for the
ride
using augmented reality the primary
augmented reality technology that the
pilot sees comes from a company called
elbit systems which makes sophisticated
helmet mount displays for the military
the capability is extended with some
technologies from the Maryland advanced
development laboratory and what's
presented to the audiences in addition
to the pilot point of view is created by
orad leader in broadcast quality
augmented reality systems the rocky
racers essentially fly inside this
tunnel that's the track they compete in
the shape of it can be infinitely varied
from something that's very simple and
reminiscent of an automobile racing
track like an oval or something far more
complex that has many many curves in it
and verticals and overlaps and loops and
and portions of the sky for aerobatic
flight
fans can enjoy rock and racing on
Jumbotrons or iPhones and iPads and when
the race is over you can still enjoy the
action yes there is now an app for that
the long range goal fans will be able to
join in and race virtual x-ray sirs
beside the real thing rocket racing may
be the first participatory spectator
sport in Tulsa Oklahoma I'm Miles
O'Brien
so I'm excited about bringing that
forward in the next year or two
so that's about getting the public
involved but ultimately to really drive
this we need to do what the United
States did 100 and 200 years ago which
is create a resource draw create
something that is so powerful that it
can literally drive the development of
new technologies and if you stop and you
think about the fact that everything we
fight wars over metals minerals real
estate energy are infinite quantities in
space and the earth it's a crumb and a
supermarket filled with resources you
can stop to realize that we're now on
the verge of being able to gain access
to all of the resources of our solar
system and the universe this is an
average-sized asteroid about a half
kilometer in size it's makeup the things
that we care about the things of life
hydrogen oxygen carbon the things that
we build buildings with you know iron
and nickel and cobalt the things which
we call rare earth metals platinum gold
and so forth that are escalating in
price rapidly 7,000 of them that we know
of astronomers believe that's about 10%
of the known population the value of
these imagine if you could go out and
capture these mine them in space
bring back the rare earth elements and
create an economy no different than the
gold rush no different than the
California land rush a single half
kilometre sized asteroid of this
platinum group market has more platinum
group metals than we've ever mined in
the history it's about a trillion
dollars worth of metals and I think that
could set off a nice space rush so I'm
gonna end with a few comments which is
to remind you that I believe that we're
living in a day and age where single
individuals and small groups can do what
only large corporations and governments
could do before the tools the
technologies are at your fingertips and
they're becoming more and more so AI
robotics nanomaterials biotechnology
quantum computing embedded network
systems all of these things they're an
exponential growth are empowering you to
make your dreams come true the question
is what are you passionate about what do
you want to go and do because the age of
personal exploration under the seas in
the air and in space is just about to
begin
thank you
Thank You Peter that was just fantastic
what a great culmination peter is
willing to field a few questions
go ahead sure a great question everybody
hear it what happens if there's an
accident commercial space I know that
during the Ansari X PRIZE I was very
clear in saying this is dangerous there
is a possibility someone will die and
and and we have to be flat-out about
that it's you know if you try and hide
it and say it's safe and so forth and
the chance of one in a hundred thousand
you're gonna defeat yourself the fact
there's a lot of people who are going
first are doing it because it's
dangerous because it's significant it
was easy like flying an airplane it
wouldn't mean as much so my point of
view is I think we have to be honest
about the fact that we're gonna do
everything we possibly can to make it
safe and let me just take a second and
and say buzz thank you for all that
you've done for this industry I'm very
grateful
[Applause]
but at the same time we can't we cannot
set expectations that when you know a
ship blows up the industry shuts down
and I think that was the problem on on
shuttle I think that's the problem on
any place where there's a false belief
so that's my belief you know whether or
not my colleagues and the in the
personal space my industry feel the way
and the same that's up to them other
questions please this is the fun part
sure so I actually had a slide over here
that talked about the rare earth
elements required for like even the
Prius and for various battery
technologies and a lot of the future
renewable resource economies we look at
are very rare earth element dependent
and I do believe that asteroid mining
it's something that I've made a personal
commitment to and something that I
believe is very doable if you look at
the degree of difficulty that the large
deep-sea oil platforms undertake in
terms of setting up robotic operations
twenty-five thousand feet under water
and then drilling down ten thousand feet
I mean the pressures the corrosive
natures and so forth I personally think
that's you know going to an asteroid for
robotic operations a cakewalk compared
to that but the economics haven't been
proven yet so my goal is actually to to
buy puts on the Platinum market an ounce
an asteroid mission cash in on the puts
and then fund the mission and go and do
it those are in the finance world might
understand them better but so besides
that I don't have much else please
squeeze in one more question if I'm a
student okay
you're all young people do it one there
one back there please sir you're a young
person life expectancy is about 200 at
this point well I mean the challenge is
that space is a risky hardware centric
operation right and it is hard to get
investments God knows I you know that's
all I've done Flast 20 years is raise
capital for my different organizations
and I think there are what's different
today is that there's a generation of
folks ranging from Elon to Paul Allen
and Richard Branson you know in their
late 30s 40s and 50s who grew up on
Apollo or early shuttle and have now
made billions of dollars transforming a
field and are now prepared to take huge
risks to make their childhood dreams
come true so a lot of times it's an
irrational investment right they're
doing it because goddammit I'm so sick
and tired of waiting for NASA to do this
I'm gonna go off and do it myself it's
sort of an attitude that comes out of
this or there's a better way to do it so
an excuse me I would be too overly
negative about my my friends at Darren's
basement administration but the fact the
matter is people when they have the
capital like Elon did out of PayPal said
oh I'm gonna go and make it happen and
that is for me one of the most important
opportunities right now the second is
hooking it up into real business models
so like we did with rocket racing or
with zero-g but zero-g still has taken
from the time we started it you know 11
years get operational we just turned
profitable last year I mean it's
incredible timelines on some of these
things so it's a passion driven
investment for a lot of folks in the
back please
so what types of problems are prizes
good for in terms of exploration they're
great for things that have a telegenic
finish things that include humans things
that are could be done but people aren't
taking the risk so our capital is not
flowing into the market so you know
could we have a New York to Paris
electric aircraft race for example
creating a Lindbergh like modern-day
version of that obviously the Ansari X
PRIZE we lucked out and worked hard to
create an event that had a great great
finishing so again it people care about
people period you know they may be
interested in the technology but they
become passionate about the news media
follows people so whenever we're
creating a prize we need to tell the
human interest story of the teams and
even on the Google Lunar XPrize it's
going to be about the teams and what
they're risking and what they're doing
and that the ads the promoters a shoe
anthropomorphize a shoe but is that word
again whatever you guys get it of the
vehicle on the moon that's what's going
to be getting people excited last
question
[Music]
so great question and thank you for
asking it it's a great place to close on
and it's the conversation I was having
earlier with a couple of students which
is the notion is you need to find
something that you're gonna do whether
you're paid or not you to find something
that is so significant and gives meaning
to your life that you wake up in the
morning and you're excited to be awake
and you go to sleep at night and you
can't wait to start the next day and you
will be told no over and over and over
again and believe me on the Ansari X
PRIZE there were there were countless
noes and when Columbia failed and I
hadn't raised the money and people
called me and said how are you gonna
raise ten million dollars when shuttle
just just fell apart or when 9/11
happened when you gonna raise ten
million dollars when you know the trade
centers are coming down but for me I
knew in my heart it was something I had
to make happen so ultimately what will
you do not for the money not because
your parents told you not because your
professor told you but because it gives
meaning to your heart and your soul and
when you find that no one can stop you
thank you